senator Elizabeth Warren is adding her
name to Bernie Sanders a single-payer
health care bill last week I told you
California Democratic senator Camilla
Harris would be co-sponsoring Bernie's
medicare-for-all bill bill a bill that
is apparently going to be ready very
very soon I still said I think it's the
right decision I support that but I
still mostly see Kamla Harris as a tool
of corporations and Democratic party
insiders and I also said the focus now
should be getting Kirsten Gillibrand
Cory Booker and Elizabeth Warren to sign
on in support of Bernie Sanders is bill
since they've said they support the idea
but hadn't yet said we will specifically
support Bernie's bill Elizabeth Warren
is signing on she wrote an email to
supporters expressing to them that they
should sign a petition showing their
support for Bernie's upcoming
medicare-for-all legislation this is
fantastic
this is terrific let's get Cory Booker
and Kirsten Gillibrand on board but I do
want to issue a sort of caveat or a
warning I do want to prepare you for
something Pat I know you're very very
anxious about this bill I read a few
reports based on knowledge of Bernie's
bill preparation that it's not really
going to be a single-payer bill I hope
that this is not the case but what I've
read is it's actually going to be a
multi payer bill with significantly
increased subsidies but it's not really
going to be Medicare with no minimum age
limit and I I don't even want to
speculate as to the details or as to why
that might be I'm withholding judgment
when we get the bill I will analyze the
bill I have the highest hopes for the
bill but I've now read that in a couple
of different places and I'm kind of
bummed out and preparing myself for the
idea that it might not just be a
medicare-for-all proposal this is news
to me now maybe it's because the
American healthcare system as it is is
so complex that they think that this
would be the most logistical ly
plausible way to push it forward I don't
know have the best chance at passing I I
could tell you and at this point is all
speculation I can't wait to see the bill
we will Anna
the bill in detail when we get it but
still three senators now supporting an
upcoming health care for all bill that's
still good the stronger the momentum
behind the bill the better this is
probably the strongest actual Senate
support for something like this even
though we don't have the details that I
can ever remember makes sense though
that Elizabeth Warren is doing it
because I think she even self describes
is the second most progressive senator
yeah and I'm just a little bit salty
though because now she's endorsing
Bernie Sanders I know when we talked
about it that there's that crazy I don't
want to rehash it because I get bummed
out every time I think about it but
Genki auger from The Young Turks
interviewed her and said so if you
basically aligned with Bernie on policy
why didn't you support him during the
primary and Elizabeth Warren gave this
bogus non answer and I like Elizabeth
Warren we've had her in our studio I've
interviewed her doesn't mean I'm not
gonna call someone out when I think that
they're wrong and her bizarre non answer
on that and you can check out that video
clip a lot of people like that video
clip I call it like I see it and that
was it was a bizarre explanation that
she gave you remember that story right
oh I do remember that story and it's
pretty transparent what the actual
reason was because she expected Hillary
Clinton to win the primaries you
probably wanted to position herself well
in that administration some even be the
VP some version of that seems to be the
most likely yeah so yeah kind of kind of
a bummer but in any case really great
now three senators supporting Bernie's
upcoming bill now all we need is the
bill great hopefully next week we can
analyze it we'll take a break we'll take
your calls and a lot of other great
stuff coming up today today's program
sponsored in part by tag adapt the
hosting specialist whether you need
dedicated server solutions virtual
private servers cloud server options
custom server solutions colocation
services whatever you need for your
business or project tag a DAB and their
expert hosting specialists and support
will set you up with what works for your
business or project and their hosting
services support a really wide range of
customers and businesses around the
world including bloggers tech startups
financial traders gamers web developers
more you can use the code TDPS
20 to get a 20 british pound credit
towards cloud server options at sign up
tag adapt calm /t dps with that you can
try out their services and save 20
british pounds about 23 24 US dollars
you use the code TDPS 20 at sign up ta
ga da be calm /t dps check it out